what about choosing an agent or manager
I mean it's great to have one of the big
powerhouses want to rep you but how do
you know if that person is really for
you the same temperament the same the
truth is that you never know you know
there's a lot of selling that happens
with agents and managers court talent
but you certainly want to query your
agent manager verbally when you meet
with them what is it that they do do
they believe in general meetings do they
not believe in general meetings are they
going to get you there you're for
staffing gig do they not believe in it
do they want you to do fellowships what
do they want you to do what are they
going to do for you do they give notes
do they not give notes do they sign off
on log lines do they just want you to
write blindly and either they like it or
they don't so you really want to ask
those questions not in a disrespectful
manner but just to understand what this
particular rep is willing to do for you
with with managers the bigger question
the biggest question is do you develop
do you not develop those are two
different approaches to management do
you are you four agents are you not four
agents are you going to help me with
staffing are you not those are things
that you want to understand so that you
don't get an agent or manager and then
six months later go wait you're not
going to help me get my first TV job
wait you don't develop and I'm just
going to keep writing scripts and either
you love them or nothing happens to them
they go back on the shelf so those are
things that you really want to inquire
about with the people that you meaning
with just to understand the dynamic of
the relationships is it advisable to try
to switch agents within the same house
of representation it's rarely promoted
or allowed you know the usually agents
will move clients so that those clients
will fire one agent for another so for
example I had an a client at CAA whose
lit agent when two talents so she was
assigned another agent within the agency
because the agency didn't want to lose
her but it's considered fairly difficult
to change agencies or agents within an
agency
without burning some some relationships
the one thing that I do see happen is
say you are with a big agent in a big
agency and they're just much too busy
servicing their big clients that's when
you can come in and say listen I know
you're really busy servicing JJ Abrams
is there any way that I can be assigned
a junior agent for the day-to-day to
potentially bring somebody else onto the
team to help you out in just submissions
getting you out there be it for
assignments for staffing anything like
that
that's when you can have team growth as
opposed to just be changing camps
you